锟斤拷1
0 0 : 0 0 : 0 2 , 7 9 2 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 0
6 , 3 3 4
F r o m s a m b a b l o c o s i n B r a z
i l
t o m a s k e d b a l l s i n I t a l y . . .
0 0 : 0 0 : 0 6 , 5 8 4 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 0
9 , 5 0 1
. . . C a r n i v a l i s a t r u l y g l
o b a l
p h e n o m e n o n . . .
0 0 : 0 0 : 0 9 , 6 6 7 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 1
3 , 1 6 7
. . . c e l e b r a t e d i n o v e r 5 0
c o u n t r i e s
a r o u n d t h e w o r l d
0 0 : 0 0 : 1 6 , 9 9 9 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 2
0 , 3 7 5
C a r n i v a l o r i g i n a t e d a s a
p a g a n f e s t i v a l
i n a n c i e n t E g y p t . . .
0 0 : 0 0 : 2 0 , 5 4 2 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 2
4 , 1 6 7
. . . t o u s h e r o u t W i n t e r a n
d c e l e b r a t e
t h e b e g i n n i n g o f S p r i n g
0 0 : 0 0 : 2 5 , 2 5 0 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 2
7 , 4 5 9
W h e n A l e x a n d e r t h e G r e a t
c o n q u e r e d E g y p t . . .
0 0 : 0 0 : 2 7 , 6 2 6 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 3
0 , 3 3 4
. . . t h e A n c i e n t G r e e k s a d
o p t e d
t h e f e s t i v a l
0 0 : 0 0 : 3 1 , 6 2 6 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 3
4 , 0 4 2
T h e R o m a n s a s s i m i l a t e d t
h e
f e s t i v a l f r o m t h e G r e e k s
. . .
0 0 : 0 0 : 3 4 , 1 6 7 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 3
6 , 7 9 2
. . . a n d i t w a s l a t e r o v e r l
a i d
w i t h C h r i s t i a n m e a n i n g . . .
1 0
0 0 : 0 0 : 3 6 , 9 1 8 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 3
9 , 8 3 4
. . . t o b e c o m e t h e f e s t i v a
l o f
" C a r n e V a l e "
1 1
0 0 : 0 0 : 4 2 , 4 1 7 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 4
7 , 4 5 9
T h e w o r d , " c a r n e " m e a n s " m
e a t " i n L a t i n ,
a n d " v a l e " m e a n s " f a r e w e
l l "
1 2
0 0 : 0 0 : 4 9 , 8 3 4 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 5
3 , 3 7 5
I n t h e C a t h o l i c c a l e n d a r
" c a r n e v a l e " -
f a r e w e l l t o m e a t . . .
1 3
0 0 : 0 0 : 5 3 , 5 0 1 - - > 0 0 : 0 0 : 5
6 , 6 2 6
. . . i s a f e a s t b e f o r e t h e f
a s t o f L e n t
1 4
0 0 : 0 0 : 5 9 , 1 2 5 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 0
2 , 0 0 0
I n 1 8 t h - c e n t u r y I t a l y , p
e o p l e
p r e p a r i n g f o r L e n t . . .
1 5
0 0 : 0 1 : 0 2 , 1 6 7 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 0
6 , 8 7 6
. . . w o u l d t h r o w i n d u l g e n
t f a n c y - d r e s s
p a r t i e s a n d g o r g e b e f o r e
t h e f a s t
1 6
0 0 : 0 1 : 0 9 , 7 0 9 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 1
5 , 0 4 2
A s C h r i s t i a n i t y s p r e a d a
c r o s s E u r o p e ,
s o t o o d i d t h e c e l e b r a t i o
n o f c a r n i v a l
1 7
0 0 : 0 1 : 1 5 , 5 0 1 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 1
8 , 6 2 6
C o l o n i s a t i o n e x p o r t e d i
t a c r o s s t h e w o r l d
1 8
0 0 : 0 1 : 1 9 , 5 0 1 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 2
2 , 5 8 4
P o r t u g u e s e c o l o n i s t s t o
o k L e n t t o t h e
s h o r e s o f B r a z i l . . .
1 9
0 0 : 0 1 : 2 2 , 7 0 9 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 2
8 , 0 4 2
. . . w h e r e t h e y h a d a l s o t a
k e n a n e s t i m a t e d
f o u r m i l l i o n A f r i c a n s l a
v e s
2 0
0 0 : 0 1 : 2 9 , 7 5 1 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 3
2 , 9 5 8
O v e r t i m e , E u r o p e a n r i t u
a l s f u s e d w i t h
A f r i c a n o n e s . . .
2 1
0 0 : 0 1 : 3 3 , 0 4 2 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 3
6 , 7 0 9
. . . t o c r e a t e B r a z i l ' s w o
r l d f a m o u s c a r n i v a l
2 2
0 0 : 0 1 : 3 7 , 9 1 8 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 4
2 , 1 2 5
T h e f l a m b o y a n t s t r e e t p a
r t i e s a r e a
c e l e b r a t i o n o f B r a z i l ' s
m i x e d h e r i t a g e
2 3
0 0 : 0 1 : 4 2 , 7 9 2 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 4
5 , 0 8 3
A n d i t ' s b i g b u s i n e s s
2 4
0 0 : 0 1 : 4 5 , 6 6 7 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 5
1 , 5 0 1
I n 2 0 1 6 t h e c i t y o f R i o a l o
n e w e l c o m e d
1 . 1 m i l l i o n t o u r i s t s d u r
i n g c a r n i v a l . . .
2 5
0 0 : 0 1 : 5 1 , 9 5 9 - - > 0 0 : 0 1 : 5
6 , 0 0 0
. . . c o n t r i b u t i n g a r o u n d
$ 9 0 0 m i l l i o n
t o t h e c i t y ' s e c o n o m y
2 6
0 0 : 0 2 : 0 0 , 2 9 2 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 0
2 , 1 6 7
O n t h e C a r i b b e a n i s l a n d o
f T r i n i d a d . . .
2 7
0 0 : 0 2 : 0 2 , 2 9 2 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 0
5 , 8 3 4
. . . t h e f e s t i v a l o f L e n t w
a s i n t r o d u c e d b y
F r e n c h c o l o n i s t s
2 8
0 0 : 0 2 : 0 7 , 8 7 6 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 1
1 , 9 1 8
S l a v e s , e x c l u d e d f r o m t h
e s e c e l e b r a t i o n s ,
c r e a t e d t h e i r o w n p a r t i e
s . . .
2 9
0 0 : 0 2 : 1 2 , 0 8 3 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 1
6 , 2 9 2
. . . t o t h e s o u n d t r a c k o f C
a l y p s o m u s i c ,
w h i c h m o c k e d t h e F r e n c h
3 0
0 0 : 0 2 : 1 6 , 4 1 7 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 2
0 , 6 2 6
T h i s i s n o w a n i n t e g r a l p a
r t o f
T r i n i d a d ' s c a r n i v a l
3 1
0 0 : 0 2 : 2 2 , 6 2 6 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 2
6 , 2 5 0
I n I n d i a , c a r n i v a l i s o n l
y c e l e b r a t e d
i n t h e s o u t h e r n s t a t e o f G
o a . . .
3 2
0 0 : 0 2 : 2 6 , 3 7 5 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 3
0 , 2 0 9
. . . w h e r e P o r t u g u e s e c o l
o n i s t s r u l e d
f o r o v e r f o u r c e n t u r i e s
3 3
0 0 : 0 2 : 3 1 , 5 4 2 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 3
6 , 5 4 2
P a r a d e s o c c u r t h r o u g h o u
t t h e s t a t e w i t h
b a n d s , d a n c e s , a n d f l o a t
s
3 4
0 0 : 0 2 : 3 7 , 1 6 7 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 4
0 , 9 9 9
C a r n i v a l i s k n o w n a s M a r d
i G r a s i n t h e
A m e r i c a n c i t y o f N e w O r l e
a n s . . .
3 5
0 0 : 0 2 : 4 1 , 0 8 3 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 4
6 , 2 0 9
. . . a n d c o n t r i b u t e s o v e r
2 % t o t h e c i t y ' s G D P
3 6
0 0 : 0 2 : 4 6 , 8 3 4 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 4
9 , 6 2 6
C a r n i v a l i s n o t j u s t a p a r
t y i n t h e s u n
3 7
0 0 : 0 2 : 5 0 , 3 3 4 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 5
4 , 7 9 2
Q u e b e c h o l d s t h e t h i r d b i
g g e s t c a r n i v a l
c e l e b r a t i o n i n t h e w o r l d
3 8
0 0 : 0 2 : 5 5 , 8 3 4 - - > 0 0 : 0 2 : 5
9 , 9 1 8
F r o m h u m b l e b e g i n n i n g s , c
a r n i v a l h a s
b e c o m e a t r u l y g l o b a l c e l
e b r a t i o n , w i t h . . .
3 9
0 0 : 0 3 : 0 0 , 0 4 2 - - > 0 0 : 0 3 : 0
5 , 7 9 2
. . . m i l l i o n s o f r e v e l l e r
s a l l o v e r t h e w o r l d
c o n t r i b u t i n g b i l l i o n s o
f d o l l a r s t o t h e p a r t y